more and more I have this intuition that  the world is like a literary  construction of some sort but this this  is much more like a novel than it is  like the world of physics an entropy and  equilibrium but we're cheerfully assured  we shouldn't believe it is because what  we feel in our own lives I think is the  invisible hand of an author moving us to  this affair this decision to move this  career choice this drug trip is so forth  and so on I mean it is a very author  feeling to reality and it hints but as  it says in Moby Dick and visible things  are but as pasteboard masks if you would  strike strike through the mass and  similarly obsessed and transform them  through raising